hey what's going on my name is Alan
dragu and on this YouTube channel I'm
going to help you write emails that
people love to read and love to buy from
listen I'm not here to help you land
more clients or do a bunch of work for
other people my job is to help you build
your personal list with relationships
with people that you personally want to
connect with and sell your personal
stuff this channel is all about you but
I guess you probably want to know a
little bit about me so a little bit
about me is I currently write my own
daily newsletter at Allan dru.com and
Shameless plug if you are not currently
on my email list go ahead to my website
right now alland dru.com and go ahead
and jump in I have a free gift for you
when you jump in but over the last 10
years I've been a Serial entrepreneur
launching over 19 startups many of them
failed it's true many of them failed but
a lot of them did really well in fact I
sold over
$350,000 through email marketing selling
my own stuff physical and digital things
as well and that's not counting the
things I helped other people sell
currently I lead alongside an
advertising agency that does
$110,000 a monthly recurring revenue and
I'm also the number one best seller of
the book meaningful marketing which it's
right here look at that it was right
there Shameless plug again wow so many
Shameless plugs I do all of this this
alongside my beautiful family I have a
wife of 12 Years her name is Adriana and
we have three kids Haley Liam and Luca
Haley's eight Liam's four Luca is two
but now that you know a little bit about
me I would love to know about you so
drop your name in the comments and
shamelessly plug your email list so I
know where to check you out where other
people could check you out exactly what
you talk about what you write copy for
so excited to get to know you but Lastly
lastly let's wrap this up before you go
I have a gift for you so in the
description I'm going to give you my
free toolkit copyrighting Catalyst that
includes 63 Cash Cow copyrighting
tactics that you can read in 90 seconds
or less each and start applying a tactic
today no need to thank me you are
welcome I hope you really enjoy it and
before you head out last thing last
thing I I promise last thing like And
subscribe this video it helps the
channel so so much so if you want to see
more about email copyrighting building
your own list selling your own stuff
Jump Right In I'm excited let's do this
see you on the next one bye yeah I know
you're going to wonder what's on the
wall behind me it's it's not a lot okay
the goat if you haven't read this it's a
good book breakr advertising I got a
couple watches back I have a watch
problem lately so I don't know what's up
with that and video games I love
to play video gam anyhoo hey that's
what's on my wall okay that's what's on
my wall bye bye I'll see you on the next
one